all the Republican candidates are
constantly bashing Muslims in the media
Ben Carson Donald Trump the biggest
bigots
an American Muslim student I'm
constantly trying to raise awareness and
make sure that everyone is treated
equally in this country so President to
the next president United States what do
you think about that
there is a lot of anger being generated
hatred being generated against Muslims
in this country that's absolutely
correct there is hatred being generated
against immigrants in this country and
if we stand for anything we have got to
stand together and end all forms of
racism I will lead that effort as
president of the United States
[Applause]
you
[Music]